l'autriche à contre-courant face à la
pandémie de kovy de 19
ce lundi les autorités du pays ont fait
savoir qu'elles prévoyaient la
réouverture des terrasses cafés et
restaurants dans le courant du mois de
mars
un assouplissement des mesures à
condition de limiter les nouveaux cas de
contamination
nous voulons arriver à pâques sans que
le nombre de personnes infectées
n'augmente de façon explosive
mais si les chiffres connaissent une
croissance exponentielle
il faudra se passer de ces
assouplissements autres pays concernés
par la levée des restrictions la croatie
après presque quatre mois de fermeture
les restaurants et cafés ont rouvert
leurs portes ce lundi dans le centre
ville de zagreb
les terrasses ou été vite prise d'assaut
par les clients nous sommes très heureux
que les bars ouvre enfin nous attendions
tous ce moment on espérait pouvoir
ouvrir vers le premier ou le 15 février
j'espère juste que les chiffres ne vont
pas encore augmenté et qu'ils devront à
nouveau fermé
si nous respectons les mesures
épidémiologique tout ira bien
nous pouvons profiter de nos amis boire
un café ensemble parler et profiter du
beau temps
j'espère que ça ira mieux une décision
gouvernementale en faveur de la reprise
économique alors même que la croatie est
confronté à l'émergence dé souche
britannique et sud africaines du virus
l'allemagne s'est également positionnée
afin de relancer l'économie du pays
lourdement affectés par la pandémie
le land du brandebourg est celui de
bavière ont ainsi autorisé la
réouverture des fleuristes et des
magasins spécialisés dans le jardinage
une décision approuvée par les clients
ravis de ce quasi retour à la normale
[Musique]
oui c'est déjà un peu un retour à la
normalité c'est sûr et peut-être que si
les magasins rouvrent progressivement
alors cela va certainement ramener un
peu de vie normale je pense que si l'on
suit les mesures d'hygiène telles
qu'elles sont décrites cela
fonctionnerait aussi la chancelière
allemande angela merkel doit rencontrer
les premiers ministres des états fédérés
à berlin ce mercredi pour discuter des
prochains assouplissement pour tenter de
ralentir la pandémie les magasins jugés
non essentiels sont fermés en allemagne
depuis le mois de décembre